so apparently there are some pretty cool
harry potter videos over on tick tock
today we're gonna take a look at some of
the top ones stick around to the end and
i'll tell you which one is my favorite
out of all of them
okay here we go
wait wait a second
wait a second that's so cool how are you
doing that i've got a nimbus 2000 oh
whoa
oh my goodness
oh my god okay wait first one we gotta
watch that again hold up he said it's a
mirror i think
dude that is incredibly clever now it's
unfortunate because it only works from a
certain angle right but dude when it is
at that angle it is incredibly
convincing man okay outfits inspired by
harry potter characters
[Music]
nice
i could see it i could see it
oh yeah absolutely
she's so expressive man look at her her
facial expressions
i don't know about harry potter for that
one
definitely draco malfoy i'm feeling that
oh that one's really good
oh that that's the best one so far
that's the best one
yep yep sorry
you know george
oh dude outside the world that's perfect
nice i like that one that's good that's
good
wait what
[Music]
oh oh
okay
wait hold on is this actually dan
radcliffe
some guy named felix he says when jenny
wants to meet in the room of request oh
we're going there okay dude holy crap
though i can't believe
this guy looks just like dan radcliff
man
[Music]
no in the last video i tried to steal
the queen's crown and now i am in
azkaban
dude people that can do stuff like this
i am not artistic in this way at all
i mean it's kind of a simple shape but
still right with a mini
a mini spatula
oh just so precise man
oh now it looks really good
i must escape
oh
dude he one-upped it there at the end
i was not expecting that at the end
oh that's cool [ __ ] more fast
he got the two mentors in at the end
oh man okay that yeah i like that a lot
super creative man
oh
oh yeah everybody loves that moment
right
once i make my move
free to check the king
no
run
her
be another voice
you want to stop snake from getting that
stone or not oh my gosh
does she have more
not me not not hermione you
once
i'm
kimberly pizzo
oh my gosh okay hold on
[Music]
watch the face
that's
that's number one so far
oh dude she's at the wizarding world now
[Music]
the laugh man is spot on
spot on
holy cow
dude this girl is so good man
kimberly pizzle everyone including
voldemort was scared of hagrid really is
one of the most powerful wizards of all
time that never got trained in
philosopher's stone he cast a spell not
once but twice without saying any words
he lights a fire and he transfigures a
tail onto dudley in half blood prince it
states that you need a mastery of magic
to be able to do this he could have been
the most powerful wizard except yeah he
got expelled and who blamed him that got
him expelled voldemort did voldemort see
the hazard of such oh
oh
that he blamed something on him to get
him expelled yeah he had to get him out
of the way
and then when he was proven that it
wasn't hagrid did the ministry of magic
give his one yeah that's kind of messed
up dude
that was kind of messed up giant and
cast spells without saying a word and
he's on the side of dumbledore of course
they didn't they were scared of him
everyone should be scared of him let the
feast
begin
dude i love ones like this where you're
trying to figure out what they're
putting together here
[Music]
no way
no way dude
[Music]
baltimore
so like what
what am i even looking at here
is this actually from the wizarding
world or
i'm assuming they made this
you can't just go buy it at the
wizarding world
insane dude
i love stuff like that man super super
artistic my wife got a delivery from
chanel but all i see is
the howler
yes
i
father is am an inquiry at work and it's
entirely your fault
yeah i can see that man it really does
look like that it's finally me and you
and you and me
[Music]
[Applause]
dude that is kind of a funny shot right
that is kind of a funny shot she's like
all hugging ron's harry's like let me
let me fit in there
please do delta deal
oh goodness
oh that looks painful
oh my gosh him in the thing
no i'm going to call him first dobby is
free
big nose there
i'm very pleased with the progress so
far yeah that's i mean we're getting
there let's help it up okay
she's actually doing the rest of it with
with the eyes still covered i'm
sacrificing my favorite pillowcase for
this
dedication oh she can still kind of see
when she looks down
why wouldn't you do save that for the
end
oh losing the ear
oh i can't put it over my head now i
can't fit in that
oh she's going all out she's trying to
do the actual pillowcase
no way yes
you got to put the ear back on
all right i've had enough of this one
like i appreciate the effort like that's
okay okay
that ups it a little bit having that
part in there
having that in there upset a little bit
okay okay okay
i'm bumping it up a bit
oh my gosh dude i forgot what she looked
like at the beginning that is crazy okay
moving on
send it send it right now
i have a door
i have a dumbo
dumbo door
oh i've seen these before
you think it's real
you think they're actually playing it on
there
because if you think about it you know
if you're if you're a good editor all
you got to do is get the sounds a couple
times
and then you could go back and record it
and make it a lot easier but that was
pretty good that was pretty good
[Music]
yep
i love hagrid in there dude
[Music]
yes i love hagrid in there
that's the perfect end no no no no no
that's the perfect end
oh that's the perfect end love it
come here beautiful boy
i love you so much oh no no no no no no
no no no no no
not today malfoy stop attacking me
malfoy stop
you're kicking me
please
oh my goodness dude
oh dude i haven't been on this ride yet
oh wait is this the uh oh this is the
flying hippogriff one i think i have
been on this one yeah yeah i have been
on this one i've only been to the park
before they opened the diagon alley
section
so when it was just hogwarts is when i
was there now they've added a lot more
but i did ride this one
guys let me know down in the comments
which one was your favorite video from
today my favorite video by far i think i
gotta go with kimberly pizzo here
absolutely insane impressions the facial
expressions just make it perfect
can't wait to hear from you guys as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon